helmes ist wieder frei die deutsche
wurde in bagdad entführt am montag
heute ist sie wieder freigekommen
darüber möchte ich jetzt sprechen mit
bild reporter wie ein stritzel er ist
jetzt bei mir im studio und begleitet
diesen fall seit anfang an herzlich
willkommen gehören ich freue mich sehr
über deinen besuch was weiß man jetzt
genaueres über diese befreiung also über
die befreiung tatsächlich noch nicht
viel genau ist außer der aus der
tatsache dass das irakische militär die
befreiung verkündet hat gegen gegen 7
uhr deutscher zeit
ich nehme an dass da keine
befreiungsaktion gab im sinne einer
militärischen kommando operationen und
dergleichen sondern das dass er das
ergebnis von verhandlungen gewesen sein
wird
darauf deutet unter anderem das
statement eines sprechers des mitglieds
bündnisses hashani der nämlich hat
unmittelbar nach der nach der
freilassung von davis gefordert dass die
irakischen sicherheitsbehörden noch
einmal überprüfen mögen warum heller
mevis acht jahre lang wie er sich
ausdrückt im geheimen gearbeitet hat im
irak und ohne sicherheitsüberprüfung das
deutet darauf hin dass dieses milizen
bündnis das gegen die irakische
regierung teilweise arbeitet in diese in
dieser entführung mit involviert war
oder zumindest teile davon dass man
davon kenntnis hatte und dass eben diese
freilassung jetzt ergebnis der
verhandlungen zwischen der regulären
irakischen regierung und teilen dieses
milizen bündnisses ist berichtet uns
mehr über heller mädels und ihrer arbeit
was macht er sie denn überhaupt zum ziel
für eine entführung in bagdad also sie
hat dort als sogenannte
kulturvermittlerin gearbeitet hat mit
künstlern mit aktivisten gearbeitet und
das ist glaube ich auch tatsächlich dann
was sie in den fokus rückt neben ihrer
deutsche staatsbürgerschaft ins ziel
dieser in dieser wenn wir davon ausgehen
dass dieser schiitischen islamisten aus
diesen medien bündnis waren
denn diese aktivisten mit denen helmes
gearbeitet hat die sich für einen
demokratischen irak engagieren die im
letzten
dieses jahr vergangenen jahres auf die
straße gegangen sind protestiert haben
gegen korruption für demokratie und
genau gegen dieses milizen bündnis genau
das ist das milieu in dem sich am iwes
auch zumindest mit dem künstlerischen
teil dieses milieus bewegt hat also
schon das hat sie hat sie zum ziel
gemacht und das zweite was sie zum ziel
gemacht hat was ich angesprochen habe
ihre deutsche staatsbürgerschaft
es ist bekannt dass der neue irakische
premier muss der akademien relativ gutes
verhältnis hat zu deutschland oder sich
darum bemüht hat vor einigen wochen auch
noch immer mit angela merkel telefoniert
und dieses milizen bündnis seine seine
politischen gegner die versuchen die
natürlich unter druck zu setzen
da kommt die entführung einer deutschen
staatsbürgerin natürlich ist das
natürlich für die einen ein probates
mittel um zu zeigen
der mann hat die sicherheitslage in
seinem land nicht unter kontrolle
das ist auch etwas wo man sagen kann ja
damit schafft man damit tendenziell auch
ausländische heuschrecken ausländische
investoren ab und zeigt das ist hier
nicht sicher ohne uns insofern ist hella
mir ist da glaube ich ein wenig in die
mühlen design der irakischen politik
geraten
ein glück ging dieser fall jetzt gut aus
wie ein stritzel vielen herzlichen dank
für deinen besuch hier bei uns im studio